here with more as Gabriel did Benedetti
national political reporter for Politico
Gabe a good morning after a long night
when the Senate reconvenes this
afternoon what do we expect well I think
what you're going to see on both sides
is both Democrats and Republicans are
going to go into their caucus meetings
and essentially try and figure out if
there is a way to do a short-term
spending bill here so that they have
more time to negotiate you know we keep
hearing this well we just need a little
bit more time but that's essentially
what they're looking for this morning
they understand both both sides
understand that they're kind of at a
tough moment here at political impasse
so what they're gonna try and do is
essentially make it so that the
government doesn't open on Monday closed
they don't want people to have to people
that should show up on Monday morning to
government work to not have a paycheck
so they're gonna try and figure out
there is a way to get us a few weeks
down the road but gave even if there's a
short-term extension here it seems like
this crisis doesn't end until a deal is
made on the dreamers and yet immigration
splits the Republican Party even the
Trump White House and Republicans in
Congress like almost no other issue yeah
absolutely right so Republicans
understand what a difficult situation
this is for them and this is why
Democrats feel so emboldened right now
because they understand that daca is
extremely popular right now across the
country even in some of these states
where you wouldn't think it might be so
that's why you have very few breaks away
from Democrats and that's why they
continue to hold this leverage over a
lot of Republicans but as you say that's
why a short-term spending bill isn't
going to solve anything here there is a
real looming deadline on daca in March
and so that's why you're gonna have both
sides try and say listen we can try and
keep the government open that's you know
priority number one but before long we
do need a fix on daca and whether that's
bringing Trump back into the fold oh
they have these conversations whether
it's McConnell and Schumer alone we
don't know what that's gonna look like
you did have five Democrats vote in
favor of the bill five Republicans that
voted against it what happened there
exactly well it you know you have to
look at the individual priorities of
each of those people who voted that way
on the Republican side you have people
like Rand Paul and Mike Lee who have
specific issues with the spending the
spending measures in this proposal and
then you have someone like Jeff Flake
for example who is actually talking
about daca and extending daca on the
Republican side on the Democratic side
you have some of the more conservative
members of the
kradic caucus who come from redder
states where it's not necessarily an
easy calculation for them you have
someone like doug jones the brand new
senator from Alabama who's so much of
his campaign was based around extending
chip the children's health insurance
program and when he made this vote last
night he essentially said I understand
how bad this whole thing looks to the
whole world but we need to do chip what
happened what happens to chip that could
Republicans could have reauthorized that
program last year they chose not to it
is a lot of leverage in these
negotiations what's the future of that
program I think that's something that
we're going to see both sides talk about
front and center this weekend and
hopefully in the next few days if you
ask them because this is so popular
we're standing against chip is so
unpopular yeah that this is going to be
the top priority it is a lifeline for
American children who are sick and any
needed financial assistance gave
DeBenedetti thanks for your time